monsieur septembre 2008
la marine française libère un couple de
plaisanciers français prise en otage par
des pirates dans le golfe d'aden entre
la somalie et le yémen
quelques jours plus tard nous retrouvons
le plaisancier propriétaire du voilier
le carré d'as dans le port de djibouti
je reviens parmi les plaisanciers les
copains personnes jean yves et sa femme
naviguer tranquillement quand leur
bateau soudain est abordé par des intrus
moi j'étais à l'intérieur et quand elle
a crié les pirates sont là je suis sorti
vite vite
gégé et vul kitty qui tirait j'ai
accéléré à fond ici j'ai déclenché la
balise de détresse là j'ai pris la vhf
comme ça l'a appuyé sur le bouton rouge
voilà un petit hic et puis m'aider mais
des deux fois c'est tout en même temps
quand j'ai vu le lendemain l'homme
l'embarcation touché j'ai filé un coup
de barre à fond par là comme le bateau
ait pris un peu de vitesse qui a poussé
le l'embarcation qui nous a cost est de
telle sorte que malgré tout un des
pirates est tombé à la mer et l'autre
s'est accroché la ve et a fini arrivés
sur le pont quand je les regarde aileurs
les yeux puis que j'ai vu le le
troisième il ya la bouche du canon du
revolver pas d'une automatique
je sais pas j'ai pas brillé comme j'ai
dit bon voilà c'est ils ont gagné pour
le moment va falloir jouer une autre
partie quoi
pendant 14 jours le couple de
plaisanciers va être consignés dans ces
quelques mètres carrés sous la menace de
six hommes jusqu'à l'assaut des
commandos français
une nuit championne une détonation comme
on avait prévu de faire
j'ai pris vers la dette derrière moi
comme ça puis j'ai traîné
donc j'ai ouvert la penderie je les
collais dans le placard derrière et puis
je me suis enfermé dans les toilettes ça
tiraille est un peu de l'extérieur
quelques secondes après mais on a il y
avait quelqu'un derrière les lumières
très fort très violente qui a indiqué
qu'avec quelqu'un qui est arrivé est qui
et qui appelait monsieur delà de
monsieur de l'âne et lui tenait en joue
les six gars qui était et qui était là
sur le lit je suis parti vers la vers
l'avant ou là bas m'a fait équipé avec
un gilet pare-balles casque pour nous
protéger
au départ de djibouti c'est à bord d'un
vieil antonoff 22 que nous embarquons
pour le fief des pirates
le puntland surnommé parfois pirates
landes
les pilotes sont russes la réputation de
la région ne leur fait pas peur
vous savez quoi tout landes il ya
beaucoup de pirates
s'il vous prennent un otage c'est votre
compagnie qui paiera la rançon que les
pirates ils ont peur des pilotes russes
parce que les pilotes russes sont forts
comme la vodka russe à 800 km de
djibouti le puntland est une région semi
autonome de somalie c'est au large de
ses côtes
autour de bossasso qu'ont lieu la
majorité des attaques de pirates
plus de 90 en 2008 pour la totalité des
côtes somaliennes
la région a son propre gouvernement et
sa police mais ils ne sont pas reconnus
par la communauté internationale au pied
de l'appareil à derry zac en chemise
foncé nous attend
merde
c'est un journaliste somalien membres
d'un clan importants du pays
un gage de sécurité en semaine il
n'arrêtait pas de près d'1 photo parce
que il pas ce qu'ils vont faire du fric
avec pascal va être enlevé c'est vrai
tout ça il ya la photo parce que et pas
beaucoup d'européens qui viennent notre
escorte est déjà là à derry zac a engagé
quatre gardes du corps
[Musique]
pas question d'aller chercher nous mêmes
nos visas ils nous demandent de rester
dans la voiture à côté d'eux
bizarre ok ok au km à l'est
derrière notre voiture le 4 4 des gardes
du corps avec nous bill est le porte
parole du gouvernement local
il sait que son pays a mauvaise
réputation il a tenu à nous rassurer
moussa sow c'est tranquille c'est
paisible ya pas de problème pas de
problème jamais non non nous avons
seulement quelques tracas comme dans
tous les pays mais vous avez quand même
des petits soucis avec la piraterie
parfois on a des petits soucis mais
c'est comme en amérique
c'est comme à paris il n'y a pas de
problème bien sûr pour vous la sécurité
est assurée bien sûr vous allez
constater par vous même
arrivé au port pas simple de savoir ici
qui décide
vous avez des laissez passer est ce
qu'il ya des gens armés dans la voiture
tout le gouvernement c'est qu'on arrive
au sur les paquets
[Musique]
après dix minutes de palabres la voie
est libre le port de bossasso c'est le
poumon économique du pays
c'est par ici que transitent les
marchandises en provenance des émirats
arabes moteur machine pièces détachées
les exportations se limite surtout à
quelques têtes de bétail et à des
chameaux
notre premier rendez-vous est avec ahmed
said nur le ministre de la pêche et des
transports
même dans l'enceinte du port lui aussi
se déplace avec une escorte de gardes
armés
[Musique]
il reconnaît ses difficultés à enrayer
la montée de la piraterie dans la région
on n'a pas réussi de régler nombre voilà
et si la communauté internationale
continue à attendre comme ça
ça va exploiter les bras c'est une
organisation et se trouvent partout
alain sauval
et il organise
il travaille avec les moeurs et les
pêcheurs qui qu'il est inexact
nous on n'a pas la capacité de contrôler
tous les ordis
sur lesquels le ministre lui même ne se
sent pas en sécurité l'homme préfère se
rendre à ses bureaux pour finir la
conversation qui force beaucoup de gens
d'affaires à rester trop longtemps au
même endroit est dangereux
les pirates sévissent aussi à terre ils
peuvent être prévenus que nous sommes là
le seul endroit où nous pouvons être en
sécurité
c'est notre hôtel
il est situé en périphérie de la ville à
l'abri des regards et il emploie son
propre groupe d'hommes armés
[Musique]
à l'écart du centre ville il est plus
facile à protéger
[Musique]
notre guide abdirizak veut nous montrer
des images de pirate qu'il a filmée dans
plusieurs villages de la côte
voilà le genre de hors-bord utilisés par
les pirates
et ça ce sont des bateaux mères qui
appartiennent aux bandes de pirates
quand ils font la chasse aux bateaux
étrangers des dix groupes
ce groupe de pirates restent en
permanence en mer ainsi ils pourchassent
les bateaux étrangers et les marins du
monde entier qui croisent dans les eaux
somaliennes
ici c'est la région de grade c'est un
endroit plein de pirates
ce groupe là est mélangé moitié pêcheurs
moitié pirates
celui là il est entièrement constitué de
pirates
tous ces gens scrute le passage de
bateaux au large et dès qu'il voit
passer les embarcations
ils font sur le rebord voici un groupe
de quatre pirates dans la région de la
sq oreilles disons qu'il n'appelle les
étrangers qu'il naviguait au large
dès le lendemain notre arrivée dans la
ville commence à s'ébruiter deux
inconnus veulent nous rencontrer à
l'hôtel avec des documents ce sont des
photos de deux otages allemands un
couple de plaisanciers qui ont été
capturés en mer sur leur voilier
quinze jours auparavant ces images sont
les premières preuves de leur captivité
jürgen et sabina on était jusque là sans
nouvelles d'eux ces visiteurs sont des
intermédiaires des pirates ils veulent
parler avec le gouvernement allemand
avec allemagne c'est avec elle que vous
voulez parler apparemment ils n'ont pas
mission de négocier nous sommes venus
seulement apporter les photos
mais ils nous font savoir que les
pirates souhaite entrer en contact avec
nous un dénommé youssouf doit nous a
appelés pour nous donner un rendez-vous
tu connais son nom yusuf il a été arrêté
et mis en prison il a réussi à s'évader
ce type c'est un vrai kidnappeurs si
nous avons rendez vous avec lui demain
et que nous allons de la montagne il
peut aussi nous qui n'a p nouvelles de
français je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention
oui il faut être prudent mais il suffit
de prendre plus de garde avec plus
d'armes et d'y aller je n'ai pas peur
quelques minutes plus tard
[Musique]
yusuf est en fait le négociateur des
pirates
il souhaite nous utiliser pour prouver
que les otages sont bien entre leurs
mains pour pouvoir négocier une rançon
nouvel appel
bingo
ce troisième appel comme les boys halo
jaune au matin je pars toujours nous
tout personne ok d'auto de veau et m me
if you want d'alcool somebody ok ok t'as
beau d'otto oui
toto et georgia food water for that is
ok dans d'autres mots dans true you must
white d'anthony au japon ni times ok ok
allez de tout bas
nous appellerons ce numéro en allemagne
des négociations s'engageront quelques
jours plus tard entre les autorités
allemandes et les preneurs d'otages
ce contact téléphonique en témoignent
les pirates ont ici une grande liberté
de mouvement seul un commando de pirate
a déjà été arrêtés et condamnés au
puntland
c'était en avril 2008 les pirates
avaient pris d'assaut un boutre la halle
khalidj voici des images de leur retour
au port de bossasso après leur capture
plusieurs policiers ont été blessés par
balles celui ci a été touché au bras
droit
[Musique]
les autorités ont ramenés au port ce
canot appartenant aux pirates
il possède plusieurs moteurs hors bord
et une échelle
c'est avec ce matériel qu'ils prennent à
l'abordage les gros navires ils étaient
bien armés des fusils d'assaut et au
lance-roquettes
les pirates eux aussi comptent trois
blessés dans leurs rangs
[Musique]
six mois plus tard ils sont toujours en
prison à bossasso nous nous y rendons
toujours accompagné de nos gardes du
corps
ces derniers sont plus attentifs que
jamais
désormais tout bossasso c'est qu'il y a
deux occidentaux en ville
dis moi pourquoi changer autant de route
ce matin une route différente
c'est une question de sécurité si on
prenait le même chemin
si on prenait même chemin tous les
matins un jour il pourrait nous bloquer
qui pourrait attaquer les kidnappeurs
[Musique]
la prison a été construite à la sortie
de la cité
arrêtent de filmer
ils ont l'autorisation
arrête arrête de filmer une nouvelle
fois il nous faut palabrer pour pouvoir
entrer
les prisonniers s'entassent dans des
cellules minuscules il fait 50 degrés à
l'ombre
certains sont enchaînés
il y à plus de 250 marins pris en otage
par les pirates en somalie mais il n'y a
qu'une poignée de pirates en prison ceux
de la halle khalidj capturé il ya
quelques mois
ils ont été amenés sous un préau
ils sont condamnés à vie combien de
pirates au prisonnier avez vous dise
cèdent ils sont sept
d'où vient-il ils viennent de la mer
rouge et du golfe d'aden
[Musique]
ils ont capturé un bateau nous sommes
journalistes
si vous ne voulez pas répondre c'est
votre droit ok pourquoi à touvois prison
nous n'avons rien fait nous n'avons pas
piraté deux bateaux ont les seulement
sorti péché ensuite la police du
gouvernement du puntland nous a arrêtés
on était en train de pêcher quand nous
avons vu un hélicoptère américain
on a voulu fuir et donc on a sauté dans
un bateau ouais mais seulement pour nous
protéger
difficile pourtant d'imaginer que ces
armes ne servent qu'à se défendre
le second pirates que nous interrogeons
avance d'autres arguments pour se
justifier
et si c'est que les français la maladie
pas attaquée les pirates
on sait que des bateaux de guerre
français ont attaqué des pirates
alors quand on les voit on fuit pourquoi
d'après lui il ya des pirates en somalie
ce qui n'a pas les gens sont à 100%
d'anciens pêcheurs ils avaient défilé
des navires et même des congélateurs qui
ne servent plus à rien car de gros
atouts du sinn étrangers sont venus chez
nous pêcher notre poisson fin de
l'entretien
voilà
là
les sept hommes réintègre les cellules
collectives
[Musique]
pas sûr qu'ils purgeront la totalité de
leur peine
[Musique]
dans un pays où l'état de droit est
réduit au minimum un pays ravagé par dix
huit ans de guerre civile
difficile de savoir qui est qui entre
pêcheurs et pirates
[Musique]
nous traversons la ville pour poursuivre
notre enquête
direction le port de pêche de bossasso
nous voulons y interroger les pêcheurs
sur la piraterie
plusieurs bateaux sont attendus après
leur journée en mer
[Musique]
les gardes du corps ne sont pas
tranquilles ils craignent qu'il y à des
pirates parmi les pêcheurs
des batteries là
combien de bateaux devraient arriver
une quinzaine c'est ici qu'ils vont
débarquer le bois son fils louis il y a
trop de monde aux yeux de nos
accompagnateurs à derry zac a un mauvais
pressentiment
il devrait faire que nous partions
direction notre hôtel
[Musique]
les gardes craignent que nous soyons
suivi
[Musique]
nous tombons dans une embuscade les
postes de nos gardes
tandis que le chauffeur tente de
s'éloigner en reculant
we dare dare dare dare nous finissons
par trouver un chemin
nous voilà coincé dans un embouteillage
la crainte c'est que les kidnappeurs
soit juste derrière
[Musique]
quelques coups de feu plus tard la voix
est libre mais les gardes sont encore
sous le choc
[Musique]
direction le commissariat central pour y
trouver refuge
le chef de la police le général mohamed
abdi est déjà au courant
envoyer des hommes sur place
envoyez les là bas c'était des pirates
qui nous a attaqués
peut-être des pirates je vais enquêter
et on va les arrêter
[Musique]
on attend sur la route de l'aveyron
à moi et moi
mais
visiblement youssouf l'intermédiaire des
pirates qui détiennent les otages
allemands est lui aussi déjà informé
mes hommes quadrillent le secteur ils
vont tenter de les arrêter vous essayez
merci ne vous inquiétez pas je suis très
content que vous soyez saints et saufs
merci beaucoup
dis moi qui nous a attaqués d'après toi
je ne sais pas exactement qui sont les
hommes qui nous ont attaqués d'après moi
ce sont les hommes de youssouf qui ont
fait ça pourquoi lui parce qu'il n'a pas
arrêté de m'appeler
où êtes vous vous êtes vous voulez
connaître deux horaires pour pouvoir me
tuer moi et nos gardes du corps y en a
qui a pris une balle dans la jambe
oui je l ai vu tomber à côté de moi
comment ces hommes pouvait-il savoir
comment était-il au courant dès qu'il a
appris l'événement le ministre de
l'intérieur en chemise violette vient
aux nouvelles
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ils ont essayé
mais ils n'ont pas réussi
nous sommes passés par l eos et ils sont
sortis de partout ils étaient une
dizaine
nous on n'était que quatre mais n'ont
pas pu nous avoir ils n'ont pas réussi à
enlever les deux européens et à s'enfuir
avec eux suivez nous
nous allons voir le bus au port ok on va
vous suivre le ministre tient à nous
prouver l'efficacité de ses services
il a quelque chose à nous montrer cette
fois ci sans escorte personnelle nous
accompagne une petite armée
nous retournons sur le port
ne pas se fier à son allure bonhomme le
ministre est bien accompagné c'est le
bus qui l'ont utilisée pour le
kidnapping
[Applaudissements]
là ce sont les uniformes que vos
agresseurs ont revêtu ils se sont fait
passer pour des policiers ils
appartiennent bien aux mêmes personnes
qui nous ont attaqués ce matin samy les
mêmes oui ce sont eux c'est ce bus dont
ils se sont servis pour vous enlever
s'ils m'avaient relevé il m'aurait mis
là dedans je vous le dis ces gens sont
encouragés par le paiement des rançons
s'il voit un européen
ils vont le capturer c'est la
conséquence des rançons versées donc
stoppera sont bien sûr il faut arrêter
de payer les rançons un mois plus tard
le chef de la police en béret bleu
tombera dans un guet-apens blessée de
trois balles
il en réchappera par miracle
de retour à l'hôtel nous voulons prendre
des nouvelles de notre garde du corps
qui a été blessé mais nos gars de refuse
que nous sortions nous confions une
caméra un journaliste somalien
c'est trop dangereux c'est plein de
pirates sur wii c'est trop chaud pour
vous
l'homme est soigné dans l'hôpital de
bossasso il a été opéré par un
chirurgien russe
lézina
il a reçu assez d'analgésiques pour ne
plus offrir ce n'est pas une fracture
simple les fractures simples sont en
deux morceaux dans son cas il ya dix
morceaux
nous espérons le soigner en cinq ou six
mois ils m'ont mis des broches
mais toute ma jambe me fait mal vous
avez pu voir ceux qui ont tiré sur vous
un seul oui mais je m'occupais surtout
des européens
retour de l'équipe à l'hôtel
nou lé pas eu de problème n'a pas de
problème c'est grâce aux gardes du corps
respect oui il nous protège et si vous
étiez allé seule personne ne peut y
aller seule personne et nous vous y
allez vous non vous pouvez pas parce que
vous représentez une somme de deux
millions et demi de l'art difficile de
rester davantage dans la ville désormais
les kidnappeurs nous attendent
même nos gardiens non plus très envie de
risquer leur vie
mais avant de rejoindre l'aéroport
il nous faut faire une dernière visite
[Musique]
le président du puntland veut nous voir
pour nous faire passer un message se
présenter
mr présente un truc
vous savez avant on ne paient jamais les
rançons alors pour nous c'était facile
la plupart des pays payent les rançons
maintenance et avec cet argent les
pirates s'achètent des bateaux et des
armes
c'est ça notre gros problème vous savez
en somalie le monde entier nous vend des
armes
ils disent qu'il ya un embargo sur les
mais si vous allez sur le marché
d'accord vous ne trouverez peut-être pas
de temps au cou d'avions de chasse mais
vous trouverez tout le reste
les contrebandiers du monde entier
viennent nous apporter des armes des
armes légères
2 quelles aides avez vous besoin surtout
de formation militaire et aussi des
facilités pour acquérir des bateaux
rapides des choses comme ça que
pensez-vous du gouvernement français
quand ils attaquent les pirates ils ont
fait le bon choix il fallait faire une
action militaire c'est la bonne méthode
pour libérer les bateaux
la seule chose c'est qu'il nous avait
promis de nous aider à surveiller la mer
mais quand ils ont eu fini leur travail
ils sont partis et ils ne sont jamais
revenus beaucoup
[Musique]
nous quitterons la cote des pirates deux
mois plus tard l'aéroport de stuttgart
nous avons rendez vous avec le couple
d'otages allemand ils ont été libérés
pendant l'été
ils vivaient sur leurs bateaux ils
habitent aujourd'hui dans cette petite
ville dans un appartement prêté par leur
famille
bonjour est ce que vous vous souvenez de
moi lorsque j'ai parlé au téléphone
oui vous étiez à bossasso ou à djibouti
non j'étais à bossasso au puntland à
seulement deux ou trois heures de
distance de vous
si en somalie certains otages n'ont pas
été maltraités
ça n'a pas été le cas pour jürgen et
sabina
famille puis trois fois de suite ils ont
passé ma tête dans une corde pour me
pendre
nous nous sommes battus dans le bateau
et c'est là que l'un d'eux a sorti un
pistolet automatique et l'a pointé sur
ma tête ma femme est arrivée à ce moment
là et elle a dit si vous tirez sur lui
tirer aussi sur moi elle s'est passé
entre larmes et moi un autre pirate est
arrivé et a soulevé le bras du premier
et le coup est parti au dessus de ma
tête
un jour je revenais des toilettes
je regardais un pirate qui prenaient de
l'eau et j'ai soudain remarquer un autre
homme qui avait baissé son pantalon
celui qui faisait office de traducteur
est arrivé il m'a dit si l'argent ne
vient pas d'allemagne d'ici cinq jours
mais 150 hommes qui seront ici bientôt
vont te violer un par un chaque jour
jusqu'à ce que tu meurs
pendant 50 jours les pirates multiplie
les tortures physiques et psychologiques
à gauche ce jour-là un soldat me dit de
sortir pendant que ma femme est au
téléphone et une fois dehors j'ai
entendu deux coups de feu du côté où
elle était le pirate a tiré comme ça au
dessus de la tête
le milicien m'a dit à ce moment là ça y
est elle est morte et maintenant on va
te tuer toi dit à ce moment là l'un
d'entre eux m'a dit ah si toi ici sur le
petit rocher et comme je n'allais pas
assez vite à son goût
il m'a frappé avec sa crosse sur la joue
j'attendais de voir sortir la fumée du
canon et puis après ce serait fini en
fait j'ai entendu seulement un clic clic
il n'y avait rien dans larmes et sur le
chemin il m'a dit je vais vous donner
une nouvelle chance demain vous allez
appeler votre gouvernement et vous allez
demander l'argent 2 millions des
tortures avec un but bien précis que les
autorités allemandes prennent au sérieux
leurs revendications plus tard un
officier du puntland m'a dit nous les
avons payés combien mon gouvernement ne
veut pas que nous parlions de l'argent
mais ils ont payé
ils ont payé le gouvernement du puntland
a payé je ne peux pas vous dire que
l'allemagne a payé vous comprenez le
point ce lundi
nous avons payé pour vous comment et qui
a donné de l'argent aux complaintes
je ne sais pas nous étions sous les
arbres
en attendant qu'ils finissent de compter
l'argent nous avons peut-être attendu
huit heures il avait un détecteur de
faux billets ces scouts
oui comme dans une banque même si le
gouvernement allemand le dément
aujourd'hui une rançon a bel et bien été
versée pour la libération de jürgen et
sabina
face aux revendications des pirates
la france elle a payé une fois pour la
libération du ponant avant d'envoyer ses
commandos depuis elle privilégie la
méthode forte
à paris c'est à l'état major de la
marine que le vice-amiral xavier magne
suis 24 heures sur 24 les opérations
dans le golfe d'aden rouge ce sont les
actes de piraterie qui ont été réussis
et jaune ce sont les tentatives
l'amiral a commandé les forces navales
françaises dans l'océan indien il a vu
de très près la montée de la menace
la première raison pour laquelle ils ont
commencé à capturer les bateaux c'était
qu'il luttait contre le pillage de leurs
ressources halieutiques
ce qui veut dire en fait beaucoup de
poissons finalement les les anciens
marins de siad barré ont commencé à agir
un peu en garde côtes
après ça a manifestement déraper un peu
c'est à dire qu'après ils ont commencé à
trouver que l'activité était peut-être
plus lucrative avec des rançons il en a
vu le taux de rançon augmenter et puis
le prix de la rançon un monte maintenant
l'ensemble de l'activité de piraterie
il dirigé par probablement un individu
avec des ramifications avec une
structure rigoureuse des gens qui en
plus une fonction de capture et les
bateaux en mer d'autres qui ont une
fonction de les garder d'autres qui vont
écouler les rançons on sent qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de se
mettre en place une structure rigoureuse
djibouti le grand port de la corne de
l'afrique la plus grande base militaire
française à l'étranger
c'est là que vient se ravitailler la
flotte de guerre française de l'océan
indien sous la protection permanente des
zodiaques des fusilliers marins
depuis 2001 la france a engagé plusieurs
navires dans le volet maritime de
l'opération hendrick freedom leur
mission lutter contre le terrorisme
et depuis quelques mois contre les
pirates
le capitaine de corvette jean baptiste
soubrier est le pacha de l'aviso
commandant birot un des deux navires
français actuellement dans la région
ce jour là l'aviso appareils pour
plusieurs semaines
à son bord une centaine d'hommes
la sortie du port est un moment délicat
c'est là que le navire est le plus
vulnérable
un hélicoptère surveille toutes les
embarcations surtout les plus petites
les plus rapides
une frégate américaine a déjà subi un
attentat en 2000 dans un port à aden au
yémen
on a failli avoir une menace embarqué
sur une embarcation rapide que ça
bourrée d'explosifs avec 1
un kamikaze on pourrait imaginer ou bien
avec simplement des gens équipés rpg
cette optique ali pour nous tirer dessus
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a les
armements qui sont son armée j'ai un
instant même du personnel derrière les
douze accusés sept millimètres d chaque
bord le 20 mm je pourrais faire usage
des armes par rapport à gym défense plus
loin un autre bâtiment de la coalition
un navire américain le
porte-hélicoptères hiroshima
des mirages français survolent aussi le
golfe d'aden les marines occidentales
sont en alerte permanente embarcation
suspecte face aux pirates
l'entraînement c'est d'abord du tir
contre eux les équipements sophistiqués
de la guerre électronique ne suffisent
pas une embarcation en ventilation de va
être été vraiment facilement maintenant
si vous n'avez 3 qui arrive
spokojny tentant même temps
là c'est du vrai harcèlement et là ça
peut être à manger nous falloir une
bonne organisation pour ne pas se
focaliser sur une seule cible mais bien
géré les trois ou les quatre
suffisamment tôt dans cette guerre
asymétrique même le faible peut menacer
le plus fort en fin d'après-midi
nouvelle alerte pour de bon cette fois
c'est évident comment dire s'ils rendent
légitime défense
c'est donc une somme actuellement en
présence de boutre avec plusieurs
petites embarcations
une remorque et une à proximité aux
moteurs qui font route
vers la côte du yémen il est vrai que ça
pourrait sembler
potentiellement des pirates
on va mettre embarcation à l'eau on va
l'essayer de on va tourner autour de
essayé de prendre contact voire un peu
tâté le terrain et en fonction d'eux
on va essayer de se faire inviter à voir
qu'on monte pour discuter récolter du
renseignement et connaître un peu le
personnes qui sont importants pour outre
peut avoir vu des pirates ou des stif
non loin d'ici donc ça nous de
recueillir ce genre de renseignements et
après le transmettra à la colonie
vous vérifiez l'amarrage de vos armes on
prévoit toujours le pire on sait jamais
ce qui peut arriver il ya deux ans ou
trois ans il ya une équipe visite
américaine qui a été prise à partie
donc vaut mieux se préparer vous c'est
donc la mer les calmes donc tranquille
à mon sens prend sa revanche la très
près c'est un bateau qui manoeuvrent en
est le but c'est pas de rester distant
le but c'est justement de se montrer
repliait de renseignement je met à l'eau
maintenant mais embarcations de manière
un peu discrète donc je l'aimé à l'eau
sur tribord et lui et sur bâbord donc il
ne vois pas mon équipe de visites
embarqué ce qui me permet de payer trop
soupçons et éventuellement s'il avait de
mauvaises intentions et bien ça
d'arrivée avec l'effet de surprise
[Musique]
d'où le bateau est aux aguets pour
couvrir les zodiac
[Musique]
j'espère que ça va bien se passer
dès qu'ils ont vu arriver les canaux
français les boutres ont stoppé leurs
machines pêcheurs ou pirates pour
l'instant impossible de savoir
l'équipe de visite montent à bord elle
n'a pas le droit de fouiller
mais les militaires pose des questions
et regarde un peu partout
un second cano a pris un peu de recul
pour embrasser toute la scène sur le
pont cette barque alimentent la
suspicion
cette flottille comprend deux gros
bateaux et plusieurs plus petit équipés
de moteurs hors-bord un dispositif
identique à celui des pirates qui
attaquaient cargo
l'aviso et maintenant tout près une
présence dissuasive
[Musique]
après une demi-heure de visite rien à
signaler
les militaires n'ont vu qu'une call
plein de poissons les boutres peuvent
repartir
l'équipe n'a pu recueillir que quelques
renseignements un des marins par le
l'arabe
vous avez pu poser de question pour des
pirates ce que vous avez vu des pirates
est ce que vous avez des problèmes avec
des pirates est ce que vous avez des
armes à bord donc quand vous fait
pirater et donc pour horizon qu'une arme
et l'orienté jamais vu ou pas là dessus
ils ont été gentiment
okapi race c'est la loi du genre ici
dans le golfe d'aden
on voit pas on n'a rien vu rien entendu
c'est bon on peut pas le vérifier il
avait rien bien vu
qu'ils prennent pas de dispositions
particulières contre les attaques de
pirates
si vous avez trouvé des armes à bord les
échelles des gros moteurs boîtes de
communication qu'est ce que j'aurais
fait des armes à bord en haute mer ce
n'est pas répréhensible par la loi
le pirate y les pirates pendant les 15
20 minutes de l'acte de piraterie
avant c'est pas un pirate peut-être
qu'il ya des arts manoir peut-être qu'il
ya des échelles mais sur quelles bases
allez-vous l'arrêter pour dire tu es un
pirate
voilà ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième c'est qu'une fois que le bateau
ait piraté
les autres sont pas faits sont prises
d'otages on peut faire une intervention
musclée une prise de before comme ça
peut être fait sur le ponant carré d'as
et là ça rentre dans un canevas il faut
prendre son temps il faut juger de
l'opportunité de la chose
bref pas facile de mettre la main sur
des pirates la zone à surveiller est
grande comme quatre fois la france un
nouveau des attaques qui ont lieu au
large
au large de la côte est de la somalie le
résumé de toutes les attaques qui ont eu
lieu dans le golfe d'aden là par contre
depuis le 16 juillet avec une forte
recrudescence depuis le
le 21 août est trop grande pour pouvoir
faire pour pouvoir assurer la zone soit
vierge
c'est en gros c'est comme si on voulait
arrêter un voleur qui est à brest alors
que on se retrouve à tous sur les mêmes
distances
il arrive pourtant que la marine
nationale arrête des pirates
ces images montrent la remise de neuf
d'entre eux aux autorités du puntland
fin octobre 2008
ces militaires sont des commandos de
marine français ils appartiennent aux
mêmes unités qui sont intervenus contre
les pirates du ponant et du carré d'as
[Musique]
avant de les faire monter sur le bateau
somaliens les commandos de marine
français coupe les liens des prisonniers
sa façade
il y en a un ça va
[Musique]
lors de l'arrestation les français ont
coulé l'embarcation des pirates est
apparemment jeté leurs armes par dessus
bord ou sur leurs armes
une telle remise de prisonniers est
exceptionnel la plupart du temps les
prises d'otages se résolvent après le
versement d'une rançon par les
gouvernements ou les armateurs à
djibouti nous retrouvons une dernière
fois dire isaac notre guide
[Musique]
il est venu de bossasso il a des
informations à nous donner
il a appris comment a été versée la
rançon pour la libération de jürgen et
sabina le couple d'allemands qui a payé
pour les otages allemands c'est le
gouvernement allemand via l'ambassade de
somalie au kenya
l'ambassadeur allemand à nairobi a donné
à l'ambassadeur de ce mali 2 millions de
dollars et l'ambassadeur somaliens à
nairobi
mohamed ali américo a pris l'avion pour
bossasso avec deux sacs contenant les
deux millions de dollars une fois à
bossasso il a suivi les procédures mises
au point avec le ministère de
l'intérieur un grand nombre de soldats
et l'ambassadeur ont embarqué dans
quatre voitures lourdement armés et sont
partis dans les montagnes du puntland
ils ont procédé à un échange de la main
à la main
je vous donne les sacs vous me donnez
les deux otages
ensuite chacun repartit son côté et ce
n'est pas tout selon lui une partie des
rançons versées par les français les
allemands étaient constitués de faux
billets à bossasso c'est un secret de
polichinelle il y a deux types de
dollars sur ce billet vous voyez le
personnage central il a de longs cheveux
c'est un vrai billet mais si le
personnage a les cheveux courts
cette info et bien que la france a payé
la rançon du ponant
c'était avec des filles cheveux courts
les allemands s'étaient mélangés
il y avait les vrais défauts mais les
pirates et ils n'ont pas vu des faux
billets si si enfin un an
il y en avait trop oui c'est ça il y
avait trop d'argent a raconté il fallait
aller vite
avant notre départ un certain bill et
wadani surnommé bill et le patriote un
pirate
veut nous faire passer un message les
français ont bafoué la loi
internationale et les droits de l'homme
également ils se sont conduits comme des
hors la loi
nous on gardait paisiblement les otages
on s'occupait de leur sécurité
on ne leur voulait aucun mal et puis les
français sont arrivés pour tuer des
innocents et mettre la pagaille
le personnage ne manque pas de culot si
le gouvernement français nous indemnise
des dégâts subis c'est une chose sinon
la prochaine fois que nous en capturant
à nous le traiterons d'une manière que
vous ne pouvez même pas imaginer les
preneurs d'otage ne désarment pas
l'europe commence à peine à réagir
les marines du monde entier ont dépêché
des navires et des sides et d'escorté en
convoi les bateaux de commerce
mais pas sûr que cela suffise à
décourager les pirates
[Musique]